so you just had a couple of hours of
hands-on time with the crew Ubisoft's a
kind of open world social racer that's
right I did drive around all over the
Americas all of the Americas so this
isn't necessarily a game where you want
to come first is it no I mean like there
is there are factions that are present
in the game and when you're part of like
when you're part of your crew both the
crew you kind of you know help each
other although that being said a lot of
it was spent accidentally crashing into
each other and hindering each other
during eraser gently accidentally so in
the crew um when we were doing like
Krugers crew races it was like a fool
via for race and it wasn't necessarily
like the person who came first meant
that their crew would be coming first it
was a point based system so we had a
case for you know someone in my crew
came first but someone in our rival
rival crew they play flex someone play
second and some place third and fourth
so they actually beat us overall in the
rest cuz they're crude and you've got
this constant sort of positive
reinforcement with these points coming
in that you're getting not just for
being in the lead or drafting you're
still like what are you trying to do II
trying to run them off the road are you
trying to just like drive recklessly
well it depends they're like lots of
different races so we did like
performance races in luck like oberoi
kind of dirt dirt bike and style dirt
track style races as well and you know
like that was just utter chaos and it
was hilarious to see but at the same
time there's like the whole leveling
system that exists in the crew so each
time you complete a race or you manage
to complete a mission you accrue you
accrue points but you that you use to
level up and like you buy new parts and
you pick up parts from each mission as
well to upgrade your car geo cars have
abilities is there anything that you can
sort of deploy while you're in a race
itself or you sort of limited to the
realistic sensation of actually just
driving a car um well it's I wouldn't
say abilities is the correct term so we
had a developer walk us through
what they were going for and he says
they actually had like item look similar
to an RPG they had items losses for the
car so you know you know how in RPGs
usually have like a homeless blood and
armor slot hand spot etc they had all
those in the car so it was like if your
car has an inventory yeah you could say
it's something quick like into their
tuning and customizing your class is a
very key element of the car experience I
want to be unique I want to cut my car
how do we make it possible for the
players to get a meaningful tuning
experience the long-lasting getting
experience we want you to make it easily
understandable and accessible and for
that RPG mechanics actually ended up
being a very good answer to make all
this process very smooth very
progressive and to put the player into
and always a positive mood of gaining
again and again and a very positively
well for all the effort you do get into
the game and going through it and answer
those RPG mechanics in the service of
making the tuning understandable and
accessible it really made sense so
another developer was talking about the
metagame with a faction that you join
and the fact that you are going to have
these seasons sort of reset at the end
of each period so you can join the
winning faction and you're not going to
get as many rewards is that right that's
right so the way that they're trying to
balance out people joining like faction
population is that you're awarded in
your faction not only for how well your
back she's doing but also your your
individual rank in the faction if you
choose a faction which is first and
which pose must play up to it then it
will be much more difficult for you to
go to the top of the rankings and your
benefits within the faction will be
lower on the other hand you can't you
can try and decide to go into a faction
with less people into it and therefore
with a much better chance of rising into
the ranks and going to the top edge
detection and they're targeting
it was funny so we try to automatically
balance this possible unbalanced by
actually making it possible for you to
get differently well depending on the
faction you choose and the risk you take
so when you actually in a race you're
not actually limited to the road itself
you can just rear off and go across
country County not necessarily um if
you're in a mission type race you do
have to follow the track and if you fear
of course then you will be you know you
won't be winning the race anymore so you
cannot if there's no purpose view
there's no reason for you to view of
course and ignore the rest together when
you join into a mission you need to
complete it to be able to reap the
reward but when you're free driving of
course you can just let go anywhere you
want yeah do whatever you want were
there any civilians on the road that was
like jump out of the way the car did you
never see another person oh no there
were plenty of civilians I mean like la
was like a living breathing hog although
I couldn't kill any pedestrians as much
as I tried they seem to be pretty
invincible